안녕하세요 시두 웨어입니다 3월은
이제 모든 브랜드에서 SS 시즌
새상품이 쏟아져 나오고 한바탕 겨울
연휴와 시즌오프가 휩쓸고 간
시기입니다 저는이 시기를 정통으로
맞았는데요 옷이라는 데로 봤을 때
저의 최근은 이렇게 정리할 수 있을
것 같습니다 교토 아울렛세일 전시
그리고
르메르이 키워드가 담긴 최근 제 구매
리스트와 다불어이 한 제 생각을
들려드리고자
합니다 처음 소개해드릴 제품은 지난
교토 여행 당시 구매한 메이븐의
본파이어 나그랑 스웨트 셔츠입니다
지금 제가 입고 있는
맨투맨이에요이 영메이븐이라는 브랜드를
들어보신 분이 계실지는 모르겠습니다
사실 저는 아예 처음 들어봤어요 저는
이걸 교토의 바라는 편집샵에서
구매했는데이 매장에 간 건 이전 여행
영상을 보신 분들이라면 아시겠지만
라든 슈메이커를 보고 구매하기
위해서였습니다 폴라드는 보면서 매장을
둘러보는데 무슨 바구니가 하나
있더라고요 바구니 안에는 빈티지
워싱이 들어간 검정색 맨투맨들이 줄에
돌돌 말려서 투박하게 늘비 있었습니다
이게 바로 영메이븐 a 제품이었는데
디피도 마음에 들고 딱 봤을 때
색상도 마음에 들어서 입어보고
구매했습니다 그런데 구매하고 나서이
브랜드를 찾아보니까 제가 생각했던
느낌과는 많이 다른 브랜드더라구요
바드에 있는 제품들은 95% 이상이
검정색으로 매장 전체가 굉장히 어둡고
조용한 분위기를 지니고 있었습니다
바잉 브랜드도 코모리 구이디 포라
슈메이커 등 화려함과는 거리가 있는
브랜드들이 그래서 당연히 검정색
맨투맨만 보고 영매 분도 차분하고
어두운 브랜드라고 생각했습니다 그런데
찾아보니까 엄청 컬러풀한
브랜드더라구요 프린팅에 들어간
티셔츠도 만듭니다 제가 생각한 무드의
브랜드가 아니라서 좀 당황하긴 했지만
그럼에도이 제품은 꽤 마음에 듭니다
저는 꽤 오랫동안 특이점이 없고 정핏
SEM 가까운 기모 없는 빈티지한
검정 맨투맨에 찾고 있었습니다
차려입는 곳만 아니면 좀 어딜가나
생각없이 꺼내 입을 수 있는 그런
맨투맨이 친환경 소재인 햄플 혼방으로
만든 이벤트에는 가먼트 워싱이
들어가서 착용감이 굉장히 편합니다
로고 플레이도 없고 특징이 있다면
넥라인이 좀 넓어요 그리고 기모 없이
얇은 느낌입니다이 부분들에서 호불호가
갈릴 순 있지만 저는 편한 느낌이
들어서
좋더라고요이 맨투맨을 무엇과 같이
입을까 생각하면 사실 어떤 하이와 잘
울릴 것 같습니다 좀 캐주얼한
느낌이라면 다 좋을 것 같아요
중청이나 노너 시드 대님 등 다 잘
어울리고 원말 웨어로 입는다면 스웨트
류의 바지도 충분할 것 같습니다 저는
평소에 100에서 100호를 입는데이
제품은 엑스라지 가니까 제가 원하던
정말 적당히 여유로운 핏이 나와서
마음에 듭니다 두 번째는 아마
등장부터 계속 보였을 제가 입고 있는
아레가 씨의 22fw 시즌 꼬니
브라운 레더 바이커 팬츠입니다 제
인생 첫 번째 가죽 바지예요 저는
에딕티드 평소에도 자주 가지만 아울레
때는 꼭 온라인이든 오프라인이든
둘러보는 편입니다 이건 최근 티드
아울렛 때 매장에 가서 구매했어요
즐비하게 걸려 있는 옷을 들쳐보고
몸에 대보고 몇 번을 둘러보면서 아
결국 구매할게 없군 하고 있었는데이
가죽 바지가 딱 구석에 걸려
있더라고요 여쭤 보니까 얘는 시즌이
좀 된 제품이라 그런지 80% 할인이
들어갔습니다 입어봤는데 사이즈도 제게
딱인 거예요 그래서 두뇌 풀가동을
하면서 고민하다가 결국 구매하게
됐습니다
이 제품을 구매한 건이 가격이 아니면
언제 좋은 가죽 바지를 제 옷장에
드리겠다는 생각이 가장 컸습니다 물론
색감도 마음에 들었어요 부드러운
이탈리안 레더로 만든 이바지는 꼬니
브라운이라는 색상 명으로 불립니다이
꽃네 브라운이라는 색감과이 가죽의
질감이 정말 잘 어우러져서 고급스러운
분위기를 자아냅니다 온라인에 동일
제품을 검색해 보니까 지퍼가 YKK
하는데 제 바지의 지퍼는 는 리리로
되어 있더라고요 이게 당연히 정품이
할텐데 아무튼 뭐 리리라 굉장히
부드럽습니다 배트가 없는 바지라
걱정을 했는데 그래도 허리에 닿는
안쪽 부분이 코듀 로이로 되어 있어서
허리가 미끄러지는 느낌은 적습니다
저는 가죽 바이라 땀 차는게 가장
걱정됐는데 제가 추운 날에만 골라
입어서 그런지 아니면 안감이 덧되어
있어 그런지 아직은 그 불편함을 잘
모르겠어요 물론 만 면 더워져서 못
입긴 할 것 같습니다 가지 고의
매력은 역시 많이 입어서 몸에 익혔을
때 오는 그 무의 금이라고 생각합니다
지금은 입은지 얼마 안 돼요 광이
굉장히 많이 도는데 저는 이걸 많이
입어서 빨리 제 몸에 익히고 광을
죽이고 싶습니다 아직은 튀는 바이긴
하지만 그렇게 되면 좀 잔잔하면서도
고급스러운 느낌이 들 것 같습니다
눈치 분들도 계시겠지만이 바지의
단점이라면 주머니가 는 겁니다
앞주머니도 뒷주머니도 하나도 없어요
벨트 없는 건 제 사이즈에 맞아서
나름 괜찮은데이 앞주머니에 손을
넣으려다가 허방을 치게 되니까 좀
허전하긴 하더라고요 그래서 이거 입을
때는 웬만해서 가방을 들고 나가려고
합니다 저는 평소에 29에서 30을
입는데 이바지는 48 사이즈를 가니까
딱 좋더라고요 지금은 편의상
스니커즈의 이바지를 입었는데 검정
첼시 부츠와 잘 붙어서 요즘은
이렇게도 자주 입고
다닙니다 그다음은 교토에서 구매한
캐피탈의 추경을 카사 자켓입니다
일본에 가면 캐피탈을 항상 가긴하지만
매번 큰 소득 없이 돌아왔어요 제가
입는 스타일이 캐피탈 럼 개성강한
느낌과 잘 안 맞아서 그런지 둘러보긴
해도 구매하고 싶은 건 크게
없었습니다 이번에 교토에 갔을 때도
목도리 사달라는 지인의 요청을 받아
캐피탈에 들린 김에 둘러보는데이
자켓을 보게 됐어요 이 자켓을 구매한
데는 크게 두 가지 이유가 있었습니다
첫 번째는 역설적으로 캐피탈스 느낌이
안 들어섭니다이 옷을 입고 회사에
가서 어디 옷인지 맞춰보라고 하면
대부분 옛날 꼼대 가래 손 갔다는
얘기를 하더라고요 곧 죽어도 캐피탈에
마치는 사람은
없었습니다이 자켓은 캐피탈에서 주로
나타나는 웨스턴 한 무드의 디테일이
없습니다 그리고이 켓은 갈색과 검정색
두 색상으로 나왔는데 갈색은 때문인지
좀 캐피탈의 느낌이 묻어나는 반면에
검정은 어두워서 그 느낌마저도 잘 안
느껴집니다 이옷을 구매한 두 번째
이유는 축이기 때문인데요 제가
작년쯤부터이 추 울 재질에 확 꽂혀
버렸어요 아마 최근에 소개해 드린
포라 쇼메이커스 같은 아티잔 브랜드
때문일 겁니다 그래서 이번에 일본에
갔을 때도 가는 매장마다 슈이 있는지
물어보고 다녔습니다 그런 와중에
도하한 캐피탈에서이 제품을 마주친
거죠 나중에 찾아보니까 캐피탈에서
추로 만든 제품이 꽤 있더라고요 제가
가장 원하던 넥라인이 높은 추용호
자켓은 아니었지만 일본 느낌이 묻어난
카라리스 형태의 제품인지라 그런 데로
마음에 들어 구매하게 됐습니다
카라리스 장점이라면이 레이어링을 할
때 좀 더 자유도가 있다는 것인데
후드 집업을 지금처럼 안에 입거나
카라가 있는 셔츠 등을 안에 입으면
본인의 을 더 잘 녹여낼 수
있습니다이 제품의 단점이라면 보풀이
정말 많이 나옵니다 사실 단점이라기
단 추용호 제품의 특징인데요이 보풀
관리가 괜찮다면 편안하면서도 빈티지한
식용을 하나 고려해 보는 것도
추천드립니다네 번째는 르메르의
eoss 소프트 박시 블루종입니다
워낙 지난해 좋은 성과를 거둔
르메르이기 때문에 올해는 좀
작년만큼은 아닐 수 있겠다는 생각 을
잠깐 했었습니다 그런데 올해도 역시나
옷들이 다 예쁘더라고요 르메르 늘
그렇듯 몇 시즌 완전히 새로운 옷을
내진 않습니다 기존에 갖고 있던
제품들의 소재나 색감을 시즌에 맞춰
수정하고 패턴을 조금 손보는 등
작지만 시즌 전체를 관통하는 작업에
거칩니다 물론 기업 백이나 포춘 백
등 신규 제품을 출시하기도 하는데이
제품들의 반응 또한 매우 뜨겁습니다
제가 구매한이 르메르의 레더 블루종은
은 이전 시즌들에 몇 차례
출시됐습니다 한 달 전쯤 선배들이랑
모여서 한남 르메이 갔었는데 선배들이
보고 싶어하던이 레더 블루 종을 저도
입어 보니까 이게 너무 예쁘더라고요
제 사이즈가 마지막 패스라는이
폭력적인 얘기를 듣고 고민하다가
결국은 제 옷장으로 들어오게
됐습니다 겉으로 보이는 특징들을
살펴보면 일단 스탠드 칼라로 되어
있습니다 다 잠갔을 때 목을 압박하는
느낌이 안 들고 딱 넥라인의 정리해
주는 정도라서 마음에 듭니다 기장이
조금 짧은 편이고 뒷부분 끝단에
탄성이 있어서 등판에 볼륨감을 만들어
줍니다 자세히 살펴봤을 때도 잘 만든
옷이라는 느낌이 확실히 드는데요
마감은 당연히 깔끔하고이 손목 스냅
안쪽 부분도 심지어 가죽으로
처리했더라면 바로이 가죽의 재질입니다
소프트 램 레더 양가죽으로 만든이
블루종을 만져보면 정말 격적으로
부드럽습니다 굉장히 얇으면서 부드러운
가죽인데 제가 경험해본 다른 가죽
제품들에서 한 번도 느껴본 적 없는
고급스러운 느낌입니다 물론 그렇기
때문에 각 잡히는 가죽의 느낌을
선호하는 분들에게는 적합한 선택지는
아닐 듯합니다 이름 그대로 박시한
실루엣 지었고 크롭한 제품인지라
허리라인이 좀 높게 올라오는 제품과
함께 입는게 잘 어울립니다 저는
메르에서 예전에 나왔던 부 대님을
함께 입었는데이 제품이 하이웨이스트라
잘 붙는 듯합니다 본래 가죽 자켓들을
입었을 때 그 소위 말해 상남자
상여자 느낌이 들잖아요 좀 강해
보이고 그런데이 제품은 입었을 때
보시다시피 강해 보인다기보다
르메르 부드럽고 고급스러운 느낌이
부각됩니다 저는 평소에 백에서 백호를
입고이 제품은 미디엄 사이즈를
입었는데 딱 좋은 사이즈가 나옵니다이
제품은 품보다 기장 때문에 180을
넘는 분들은 라지 사이즈 가시는 걸
추천드립니다 마지막은 혀와
프라그먼트의 협업으로 출시된 파자마
세트입니다 저는 마음의 방이 많은만큼
좋아하는 가수도 정말 다양하지만
혁오는 정말 제 한손안에 꼽을 수
있는 아티스트입니다 그래서 당연하게도
지난 전시도 갔었고 다가오는 앵콜
콘서트도 정말 운 좋게 가게
됐습니다 이름이 파자마세트 하지만
제가 본래 잠옷을 따로 입지도 않고
이 제품은 또 주름이 잘 가는
면소재라 그냥 평소에 입기 위해서
구매했어요 구매한 이유는 솔직하게
절반은 팬이고 절반은 편하게 입을 수
있는 셔츠 셋업이 때문입니다 이번
lpc 세트를 포함해서이 제품도
후지와 히로시의 프라그먼트와
함께했습니다 제품을 보니까 제작
자체는 소프트 오피스에서
맡았더라면이 소재나 제품 자체 질이
떨어지거나 그러진 않습니다이 제품은
그냥 편하게 입고 싶대 눈에 띄고
싶지 않은 날 입기 좋을 것 같습니다
셋업의 장점이 그렇잖아요 생각없이
나갈 때 그냥 위아래 꺼내 입으면
중간은 가는게 셋업이 그요 그리고
색감만 오시니까 틀 릴도 없습니다
바지가 좀 독특한데 지퍼 플라이 등의
방식이 아니고 왼쪽 허리춤에 길게
늘어진 스트링이 있습니다 이걸 조이고
풀어서 사이즈를 조절할 수가 있어요
그래서 바지가 좀 허리가 크게 나와서
프리 사이즈로 나왔습니다 상하이 모두
굉장히 넉넉한 실루엣으로 나왔는데
그러다 보니 좀 편안한 느낌으로
입기에 안성 맞춤인
옷입니다 교토 여행 때 구매한
제품들부터 해서 몇 가지 소개해
봤는데 가끔씩 구매한 것들을 공유하고
털고 가도록 하겠습니다 몇 개 소개
못 한 것도 있는데 그건 다른
영상들에서 끄집어내 보도록 하겠습니다
오늘 제 이야기는 여기까지입니다
감사합니다 l